[Música]
la organización de naciones unidas
mejoró la previsión de crecimiento para
américa latina con esto comenzamos
economía en france24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniel hablando en daniela muy
buenas noches mejores perspectivas
entonces para la región así de santiago
muy buenas noches en el informe de enero
naciones unidas- creía que la economía
de latinoamérica y el caribe iba a
crecer 38 % ahora la previsión es
levemente superior del 43 por ciento por
subregiones el mayor crecimiento
esperado es para méxico y centroamérica
le sigue el caribe con 4,3 por ciento y
al final de la tabla suramérica esto
último se debe a que según la onu hay
países para los que todavía no ha pasado
lo peor y se los enumeró brasil
argentina perú y colombia a nivel global
el organismo también encendió aún más la
luz de esperanza dijo en ese sentido que
espera un aumento del 54 por ciento en
el pib mundial gracias al impulso de
eeuu y de china hablemos ahora de españa
que aprobó la ley de formalización
laboral para las personas que trabajan
en
relacionadas con las entregas a
domicilio santiago esta nueva norma
conocida como la ley ryder da un plazo
hasta mediados de agosto para que las
aplicaciones como uber its delivery o
globo contraten formalmente a sus
domiciliarios esto después de todas las
críticas que han recibido por supuestas
condiciones laborales precarias y bajos
salarios se estima que la norma cobijar
a unos 30.000 de ellos a quienes les
pagarán prestaciones y podrán acceder a
beneficios como subsidios de desempleo
vacaciones o una pensión el ejecutivo
defendió la medida santiago pero una
cosa es lo que piensa el gobierno y otra
lo que piensan muchos de estos
trabajadores que hoy salieron a
protestar escuchemos por qué
las tarifas actualmente no son las
mejores pero si nos ofrecen una
comodidad económica para solventar nos y
pues el hecho de que nos laboral issl
implicaría que tendríamos que cumplir
unos horarios vale y lógicamente
nuestros nuestros ingresos se verían
bastante afectados daniela la ocde o la
osce de pidió a los países subir los
impuestos sobre las herencias sí señor
el club de países ricos como también se
le conoce dijo que de esta manera se
podrían eliminar las desigualdades ya
que estos gravámenes apenas representan
el 0 5 por ciento de los ingresos
fiscales de sus 24 países miembros la
ocde cree que en promedio las herencias
recibidas por el 20% más rico de los
hogares son cerca de 50 veces más altas
que las que recibe el 20% más pobre pone
como el peor ejemplo a eeuu allí apenas
el 0,2 por ciento de las propiedades
paga impuestos por herencia y el 80% de
la riqueza está concentrado en apenas un
puñado de multimillonarios que son el 10
por ciento de la población según la o se
debe pues esto refleja una gran
desigualdad pasamos ahora a honduras
este país presentó un plan nacional para
reconstrucción después del paso de
varios
carnes por ese territorio de
centroamérica bueno el proyecto de siete
mil 875 millones de dólares fue
presentado ante la comunidad
internacional como una hoja de ruta de
cara a la recuperación del devastador
paso de las tormentas tropicales y otra
dieta que en noviembre de 2020 azotaron
al país hay un análisis santiago de la
comisión para américa latina y el caribe
que dice que estos fenómenos naturales
afectaron a casi medio millón de
personas directamente y también a casi 4
millones de manera indirecta se cree
también que el impacto económico superó
los 2 mil millones de dólares el plan
ahora cual es desarrollar 85 proyectos a
corto mediano y largo plazo lo que no
está muy claro es de dónde van a salir
todos estos recursos porque representan
casi una tercera parte del pib del país
hablemos ahora de los indicadores como
los suelos principales bolsas en la
jornada de hoy
santiago el miedo a que se dispare la
inflación hizo temblar las bolsas del
mundo la inflación en eeuu wall street'
por ejemplo cerró con pérdidas ante la
expectativa por este dato que se
a conocer el miércoles por el mismo
motivo las acciones europeas cayeron
desde los máximos históricos que habían
anotado el lunes y el panorama fue
similar en américa latina con la
argentina cayendo más del 1 por ciento
cifra del día para el cierre 485 mil
millones de dólares esto han irrigado
los gobiernos de américa latina en
apoyos fiscales durante la pandemia con
paquetes que representaron alrededor del
85 por ciento del pib santiago dice que
las comparaciones son odiosas pero hay
que hacerlas en este caso mire la unión
europea y eeuu cada uno destinó 12 veces
más de esa cantidad para pues que todas
las regiones de latinoamérica para las
crisis fiscales gracias daniela por esta
actualización es todo en economía en
france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]